[Music]
[Music]
hello you took chess Louis and my
friends this is guns in here welcome to
my second episode of killer mini chess
traps this practical small traps are
very effective in short time control
match and specially below 2000
tournaments they are very cunning and
not easy to spot and that's why you can
caught lot of your opponent off guard
and get a winning position just within
the opening stage in this episode I'm
going to show you three traps from the
wide perspective and the content are as
follow
you
the first rap which is more common and
frequently appear on the board and that
goes with Queens gambit declined
exchange variation which happens after
the water d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight
to c3 and defy we have the qgd on the
board okay
white exchange in the center with C
capsules D Phi e captures D Phi and now
the tamasic move Bishop to g5 so if
black is not careful then what he's
going to lop up that night and either
black has to capture with the Queen and
give up the d5 pawn or completely
shatter the King side pawn structure so
accordingly Bishop to e7 saving the
threat and now white liberate his other
Bishop with III okay the most initial
move in the world castle on the Kings
side and now the cunning move Bishop to
d3 and the trap is set right here
here the mainline moves are continued
with either Knight B to d7 or the move
c6 however if you check this position in
online database you will find out that
there are actually three hundred and
eighty-two games start with b6 which in
fact one of the most natural move in
this position black wants to play Bishop
to b7 Knight B to d7 c5 and a kind of
Moran structure which gives him a
rock-solid position but except there's a
huge problem that after this move white
is instantly winning before I move on I
like you to pause this video and find
out the amazing sequence which gives Y a
completely upper hand okay then let's
start the first move is very obvious
destroying the defender of the defense
we're with Bishop captures f6 and after
Bishop captures f6 White has this little
blue yup Queen to h5 BAM
well this queen is attacking to spot at
7 as well as d5 and I think at some is
more important because that's
threatening a checkmate and it doesn't
matter whether you opponent continue
with either the move at 6 or g6 let's
say in this game black continue with g6
but now comes Queen captures defy and
suddenly just within 10 more of the game
white emerged with an extra pawn and
with some accurate play this is easily
converted into the full point so this is
one of the cunning trap exist in the
Queens gambit declined exchange
variation and so far this year there are
more than 20 victims including one 2300
fall into this
the second cute trap exists in the
French Blackburn variation which arises
after the following model E 4 e 6 d4 d5
Knight to c3 or night to d2 doesn't
matter
black intention is he wants to play he
captures Evo and after Knight captures
evil black follow up with Knight to d7
so as you can see I have highlighted by
the arrows black as a simple plan he
wants to play Knight to f6 exchange a
pair of 9 and slowly take out all the
pieces ok no problem
white will continue with Bishop to d3
and after the move Knight to f6 I
propose this very trap EMU Quint we do
well at first sight this looks so stupid
right because now black can take this
Knight and it doesn't matter however
recapture the base recapture is Bishop
captures efore and after that black can
play the move Knight to f6 not only
hitting the bishop but hitting to lose
d4 pawn and it looks like white cannot
bury both the threat well in fact that's
the case in the database where I found
out 162 games reach to this position
where the matter of fact is it's
actually black who has fallen into the
white trapping business once again
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a sequence where
white has are completely upper hand
are you ready did you find this decisive
blow boom
so suddenly white one upon and more
important white Bishop is hitting the
rope so black responds his force black
has to take this bishop and after that
yup the easiest by queen-to-be file
check regaining the piece and after
something like Knight to d7 and Queen
captures b7 not only white emerged with
an extra pawn but black Queen side has
completely shattered and once again with
some accurately white can easily win
dispositions so next time when you open
in place French black band variation
against you don't forget to shock him
with this nasty trap last but not least
I'm going to show you one of the high
profile trap in the Tauri attack which
arises after the following water d4
Knight to f6 Knight to f3 d6 and now the
typical Tori attack move Bishop to g5 so
this opening is very effective
especially if your opponent is playing
the nimzo-indian setter what simple idea
is he wants to play he fall and grab the
center immediately so accordingly black
stop this with defy controlling the e4
square and now simply white develop his
rest of the army like this III Knight B
to d7
Knight B to D to c5 c3 so you can see
White has created this solid pawn chain
and the most important factor is this
Bishop is outside the pawn chain and on
the counter part black is going to go
with this Moran kind of setup with
Bishop to e7 unpinning the Knight Bishop
to d3
looking on the black kingside and after
black castle and white castle the only
piece hasn't developed in the black camp
is bishop and just like qgd structures
this bishop is going to develop on the
b7 square with b6 and after white plays
queen to e4 Bishop to b7 is initial
response so this position has been
reached many times on the board where it
seems like neither side has an advantage
and black is doing quite good well yes
indeed to some extent it's true except
white has specially prepared this
amazing move Knight to e5 so idea is
very simple if black doesn't capture the
night let's say black continue with some
random move Asics then White's point is
he wants to play f4 cement that
wonderful night and after something like
rook to c8 and rook to a3 you can see
easiest attacking plan of campaign by
wide he wants to play rook to h3 put the
screen back on Devon and reroute to the
King side and if it's required then he
can also play g4 g5 and start attacking
on the black King which is always a
prison scenario for the white camp so
accordingly at this point black cannot
allow this and more often or not black
capture on e5 now before we look at this
line there is one point I like to
highlight here that if your opponent
plays at 6 then this trap won't work but
as I mentioned earlier white plan of
campaign will be more or less similar
anyways
let's check out the most popular choice
Knight captures Aoife which is more
natural in this position get rid of that
pesky night
and after the moon D captures ePHI Black
has three choices and believe me I'll
lead to losing position for the black
camp in fact in the database there are
more than 36 games played from this
position where white vinegar a show is
tremendous let me highlight what is the
big problem
Black is facing at this point the first
move I want to consider is Knight to d7
which in fact highest Lee played but I'm
afraid it is the worst more disposition
as after just one move Queen to h4 vara
mu we are checking to sports and by
force black is going to lose whole rook
yup you heard it right the whole rook
will be down well how the easiest answer
is first of all why he's attacking on at
seven so by force black has to stop that
threat and no matter however he defend
let's say at six but now comes Bishop
captures a seven not only grabbing a
piece but attacking two spots and when
the Queen moves anywhere
what will capture the rook and at the
end of the sequence white will be the
whole rook up I have personally caught
few hiring opponent in this line and I
must tell you it is not easy to spot
over the ball well the other moves are
equally not that great simple move
Knight to e4 is a bad the reason is why
twins come out as a healthy pawn up
after the following sequence Bishop
captures a 7 Queen captures e7 Knight
captures efore pawn captures e-form
Bishop captures e4 Bishop captures e4
and now Queen captures a 4 and it turns
out that
after the whole transaction white is in
a completely driving sage so that's not
something which white is looking for and
the third move Knight to h4 which is in
fact the best choice of engine also not
grade the simple reason is after Bishop
captures d7 queen catches a seven and
the move Bishop to e2 that Knight
doesn't have any back route available if
Queen to G Phi then f4 is a very strong
reply so accordingly the best move here
is g6 and after that you can easily
guessed it yep
Bishop captures h5 g captures h5
completely ruined down black King side
open up the King and later on create a
winning attack on that side of the ball
so this is one of the high profile trap
exists in the Torah attack which you
definitely want to consider in your feed
a tournament well that's it guys I hope
you enjoy and learn this wonderful
episode of killer mini chest straps feel
free to like subscribe and comment on my
video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care